are you having any negative thoughts
it's so cliche to talk about physical
transformations but when you look at
Joaquin especially in some of those you
know shirtless dancing scenes he just
told me that he wanted to gain weight
for the role you know how did this
conversation good I think that was he
was looking for the easy way out at that
point you know I think he should be more
like heavy we haven't really seen a
heavy Joker and I said you know I get it
but I really believe that art there
needs to look hungry and wolf-like and
malnourished and it was a bit of a
conversation and he just started losing
the weight he lost I think 52 pounds you
just wanted a shotgun ice cream thank
you
now there are so many iconic iterations
of joke or you know from Heath Ledger
Jack Nicholson Mark Hamill even how do
you go into this saying I'm gay you kind
of set all of that aside so how do you
make it grown while honoring what the
source material really is I think for me
and for Joaquin by ignoring the other
stuff and not in a disrespectful way but
in a way that if we looked at all that
over and over it would paralyze us with
fear because there's been so many
beautiful and great performances that we
couldn't get wrapped up in and we just
decided to kind of put our heads down
and just try and do our own thing and
you've been quoted as saying or maybe
misquoted that there was no intention of
doing a sequel but it does seem like
there's a space for that is that
something you're thinking about it
you're interested in no we really like
that this movie lives on its own fair
enough now there is a theory that
there's a lot of theories that are out
there they're gonna be so many I know do
you submit to those do you read them no
nobody tell me what this one is the one
that I think that caught my attention
the most was that the Joker in this
movie is not the real Joker it's the one
that influences the Joker that we meet
later what did you think of that you
know it's funny that that's a theory
that's out there because I I've showed
um I've showed this movie too when we
were editing I would show it to friends
of mine film
writers and one of them had that theory
and you know we I like these theories I
don't look into them because and I
definitely want to answer them but one
day I will say what we think and what we
meant when we were writing it which i
think is important but not now I like
that again you could view this movie in
many different ways
yeah that kind of goes into my next
thing is like you have this completely
unreliable narrator and right we're
talking about I mean me and my friend
that's all the only person I can really
talk to it about right now we're like
what did you think did you think this
really happened will you ever reveal
what you were thinking yeah I will one
day but I think in the far future it's
fun to sort of go back in and because
you don't want to hamper what other
people's experiences and certainly you
know you don't want to hamper other
theories that might arise from it but
again I think it's what makes the movie
do intriguing like I mentioned I after
watching this movie I went and watched
the king of comedy because I feel like
that's a central viewing like intent to
be put in this movie but Robert De Niro
is in the movie can you talk about
getting him on board and well yeah I
mean the king of comedy for me is one of
my favorite movies when I was younger
growing up and still to this day it's
very overlooked early Martin Scorsese
movie a lot of people haven't seen it
like yourself before this and so it was
a somewhat of an influence for this film
of course and De Niro being the star of
that movie I basically sent the script
to Bob when we came up with that
character and I thought wow this would
be interesting if we get Bob to do this
and he read it and we met and we talked
about it
and now he's in the movie but you know
the the correlation between the two
movies is not that direct it's just no
bit about no but I know I feel like I
like I wish I almost wish I watched it
first be like oh that was enough you
watched it after I watched it out last
night now I want to talk about the
reception for this film there was an
eight-minute standing ovation I don't
know whose timing the standing ovation
is I'm sorry I've always wondered was
there timing this but eight minutes
standing ovations there's not there's
Oscar buzz I mean what would that mean
to you I know I mean it's like don't
talk to me yeah I mean it's not
something I would want to talk about
either I mean the eight minutes an
ovation happened it was real and it's
surreal to be there for it I mean you
know the more interesting thing for us
was the movie won the Golden Lion you
know at the Venice Film Festival which
is unheard of for a comic book film be
Warner Brothers as a studio has never
won a Golden Lion there
the history of that festival is runs
deep so for us that was a major major
thing